when you eat food there's much more to
food than just the taste in addition to
the taste the texture the way the food
feels in your mouth as a good example
the steak that we have here we're going
to cook the steak and I'm going to show
you how it feels how the way it feels
changes when you cook it what that means
is when you chew on the steak how it
feels when you chew on it changes that's
the texture that's the mouthfeel and
that's determined by the elasticity of
the steak the elasticity of the steak
will increase as it becomes more
difficult to chew as we cook it for a
longer period of time so all foods have
a texture all foods have a mouthfeel if
you don't like steak for example if you
prefer tofu for your vegetarian it too
comes in different flavors it comes in
different styles you can get a firm tofu
or you can get a soft tofu a firm tofu
takes more force from your mouth to chew
it it's more elastic it's stiffer soft
tofu is much softer it's much easier to
chew and when you finish the steak and
your tofu you have dessert you have
chocolate it too comes with different
textures chocolate mousse it's light its
Airy it's very easy to chew it's a very
low elastic material the elasticity of
chocolate mousse is very low if you take
a chocolate bar it's stiffer it takes
more force to chew it its elasticity
increases and if you take real chunk
chocolate a really good Belgian
chocolate it's much stiffer you have to
bite much harder so the mouthfeel how it
tastes all is wrapped up in the
elasticity of a food and this is how we
characterize what the mouthfeel of the
food is so if we want to measure it we
have to measure the elasticity and let's
start with the very simplest thing let's
start with a spring here I have a spring
and I can hang a weight on the end of
the spring if I hang a weight on the end
of this
the spring lengthens it becomes longer
it becomes longer by a certain amount
that mount that Delta L the change in
length is determined by how stiff by how
elastic the spring is and how large the
weight is so let me hang the weight on
it the spring gets longer but then it
stops moving the forces are balanced
there's no longer a net force on the
spring the spring is exerting a force to
hold the weight up and the weight is
exerting a force to stretch the spring
we can do the same thing if instead of
lengthening the spring we compress the
spring we put the weight on top of the
spring like this if you push on the
spring and you push it down then the
spring pushes upwards it pushes in the
opposite direction it tries to bring
itself back to its original length and
we can write the relationship between
the force of the spring and the change
in the length of the spring it's called
Hookes law and it just says that the
force is linearly proportional to the
change in length this minus sign arises
because there is always a restoring
force the string spring is always trying
to retain its original length it's
trying to get longer if you're
compressing it and it's trying to get
shorter if you're extending it the
relationship between the change in
length and the force is the spring
constant and that determines the
elasticity of the spring the larger the
spring constant is the more the force it
takes to extend it by a given length so
a stiff spring has a very large spring
constant and it takes a larger force to
extend it we can use the same concept
now to describe food in the case of food
we have some object for example we have
this piece of steak we want to measure
the elasticity of a piece of steak the
force that we put on the food the force
that we put on the steak will depend on
the size of the state
so if I take a very large piece of steak
and I want to deform it I want to
squeeze it I want to change its
thickness by a certain amount it takes a
much larger force than if I take a small
piece of steak but when I tell you what
the elasticity of the steak is I don't
want to have the dimensions of the
object of the piece of steak as part of
the elasticity so I want to somehow take
out the dimensions of the state so to do
that I take the force and I normalize
the force by the area on which I apply
the force that gives me the stress the
same point I don't want to know how
thick the steak is when I compress it I
just want to know how much I compress it
for a given thickness so I take the
compression I can't take the change in
thickness as I squeeze on the steak and
I normalize it by the original length
and that gives me a strain a strain is
the relative change in length now I can
calculate the elastic constant in the
same way that I calculate the spring
constant I want to calculate the spring
constant I take a force and it divided
by a change in length for the elastic
constant of the steak I take the stress
which is the force divided by the area
and I divide that by the strain which is
the relative change in length and that
gives me the elastic constant of the
food